about cattle mutilations I'm always
interested why are they associated with
the craft I don't know I I don't have a
like even a hypothesis on that so
what do you think about cattle
mutilations
well I I do it based on the science that
Dr alt Schuler
whose stuff was ripped off by the
charlatans and the UFO subculture uh he
did the original snippy the horse Case
in Colorado and he was a hematologist
pathologist for a good friend of mine he
was also by the way the nephew of
General Jimmy Doolittle
it went over to investigate Foo Fighters
for Roosevelt and came back and said sir
those are interplanetary vehicles but at
any rate he uh lived in Denver
and uh he's passed away now he got
cancer and died but he was one of the
very early scientists looking into this
and he concluded it was a highly
classified human
uh deceptive false flag deceptive
indication and warning uh and of course
we knew that was the case and when
people see quote-unquote a UFO around
one of these events well which UFO an
Interstellar one or one out of the
lockheed's comp works I think that there
is this again everyone assumes that
anything going on there with this kind
of phenomenon has to be something we
don't understand that's mysterious it's
a little bit like The Wizard of Oz being
behind the curtain pulling all the
levers scaring the crap out of Dorothy
and the Scarecrow
um they have the ability to Stage things
that look very alien that aren't and as
you know Jacques Valley has a Dr belay
has a document from the CIA from 1985
describing the CIA program of quote
unquote
staging alien abductions in Brazil and
Argentina for its psychological warfare
purpose now you know I have a number of
men on my team who actually have been
operationally tactically involved in
those programs so if you have people
with the intention to deceive the public
and particularly the gullible UFO
Community then what happens is that
there can easily stage mutilations and
easily stage abductions and easily stage
all kinds of things
um and people are going to not be asking
the question you know is it real or is
it staged so the very first thing when I
hear something uh now I didn't know this
when I first started the project in 1990
but as I've gotten methods and sources
and assets who have been involved with
this and in this case now there are
documents that you know this is a big
problem because if if they can taint how
people view the subject and what the
database is uh by including a lot of
staged events that are human for their
psychological warfare value you then
have to go back to all your cases and
database
and start over you really have to look
at everything with a fresh look uh and
then you throw in one more confusing
element
and that is this whole interdimensional
question of entities quote unquote or
intelligences that are neither human nor
extraterrestrial
that could be in the play and so you
know this people don't like this because
people like you know simple Hollywood
movie type narratives but it is complex
and and I think that I don't think it's
beyond what people can understand but I
just think that it's not usually talked
about you will go to very few
conferences on this subject where the
whole question of the cosmology and all
the different phenomena that could be
man-made versus extraterrestrial versus
quote alien I use the word alien really
to not denote extraterrestrial so much
as what's being foisted on the public as
extraterrestrial
um and I think that's done very
deliberately because if you can
misdirect people you know there's a guy
I worked with years ago who was the
right hand guy for General Odom who is
the director of the National Security
Agency
and after he left that position he
worked with me and helped analyze
documents and stuff
um
so he knew what things should look like
uh as particularly the documents that
would come to me that are not officially
Declassified that are still top secret
that we have and so but he told me he
says yes what we do is go to DDT I said
oh that's the like the the poison you
know the whatever it was the insecticide
he says yes but it's not what it stands
for you set up a decoy you distract
people and you trash their efforts DDT
he said we run ddts on people all the
time
um and so if you're sort of like an
actor have you ever had one run on you
oh yes absolutely
more than once I mean I
well you know the the night after I I
met with um
uh
I was meeting with the Crown Prince of
Liechtenstein about Prince Hansel I
don't know about Liechtenstein and uh of
course he was trying to convince me of
the evil alien narrative so that we
could have World War III that would
bring Christ back on a flying saucer I
mean that was this whole end of the
world eschatological Armageddon sort of
speaking of World War II I want to ask a
Ukrainian UAP question so I'm just
putting that out there let's continue
please
but that but so that night when I did
buy into it this was in July of 1994.
I was targeted with one of these systems
and it was one that was trying to abduct
Me Out of the my hotel room in St Moritz
Hotel and luckily I I identified it
right away as uh directional energy
weapon that was attempting to to do this
um but you know that with that sort of
nonsense has been played on people for
decades remember we took in Havana
syndrome yes way beyond that I mean the
Havana syndrome stuff would be the very
tip of an iceberg uh
electromagnetic Warfare systems that are
more trans-dimensional and that are uh
dealing with more scalar longitudinal
type
energy and so-called psychotronic
radionic but very Advanced versions of
it
um and those those are what are used
often and deployed along with other
means uh during abduction sequences by
these human
uh well criminals I mean you know I mean
one of the things I'm saying to these
folks here in Washington I said you have
to understand you're going to uncover
the largest Ricoh in the world
racketeering influence corrupt
organization uh and they have
Technologies and and the means to to
make a lot of trouble and you have to
approach this carefully so the whole
system doesn't get blown to Pieces but
but they have these abilities and I
describe them I go from the sort of easy
to understand anti-gravity device
floating over the desert that looks like
an alien ship that came out of
underground at dugway that's made by
Northrop Grumman or something versus you
know these really esoteric
trans-dimensional systems that are
man-made and that can stage and deceive
people quite easily and they're very
good at this by the way you know and
they've been perfecting it from the 50s
in the early days
they used a short statured guys with
made them up in Hollywood type things on
board uh man-made craft and then would
engage in abductions using so a canister
or some knockout chemical and what have
you but as they develop more and more
capabilities in these electronic warfare
systems they then also created these
sort of robotic
what look like aliens the Grays and you
know I know a number of guys
but very very similar at the level of
almost a nano bio machine
uh type of thing and those are those are
what your typical abduction sequence
Critters uh you know and we know exactly
you know where they're being made who's
making them how they make them how
they're deployed
um and by the way there was an expose on
this in the 80s before I got on the
scene uh by a researcher uh but of
course he got booed out of the system
because it blew up everyone's uh belief
system of the good and the bad aliens
and you know they look they want
everyone to be addicted to some other
narrative to replace racism and uh
division on the planet they want the
humans to be United but against an alien
threat it's a it's a very simple
narrative
um and it's what demagogues have done
you know for thousands of years to
consolidate power but this is on a
larger scale than just the British
staging you know and and setting up the
maori's fighting against each other in
Louisiana Island so that they could go
in the breach and Conquer New Zealand so
that you know this is a much more
sophisticated high-tech version of that
but that's but that's been a strategy
that the military planners have done for
thousands of years but in this case
you're dealing with some very Advanced
Technologies quite capable of deceiving
almost everyone involved and that's
that's a problem because ultimately what
that creates uh is you know how do you
begin to have do you have to set up a
system where anything that happens goes
through a whole analysis of uh you know
is it this this this or this and you
know there's a whole set of things that
might be and I don't see that people are
doing that it's a little bit I liken
this to a doctor someone comes in with
chest pain and they're so poorly trained
they have to conclude it's a heart
attack and treat them for a heart attack
when it could be a dissecting thoracic
aneurysm or pleurisy or uh pulmonary
embolus or I mean it could be a hundred
things yeah right it could be all kinds
of things so
um what we have in this subject right
now is a crisis in analytics and
knowledge and information because the
the truth is the strangest things are
real and many of them are human in
origin uh now there are the high
strangeness aspects of the ET uh events
and they're the highest strangest nature
of the interdimensional events the sort
of the Montauk type scenario